too close to call this morning a pair of
hotly contested congressional races
democrats susie lee and steven horsford
were really trying to hold on to their
seats
they represent districts three and four
here in the valley our hector mejia is
live in the west part of town with the
latest on these races good morning
hector
good morning and this one is also a nail
biter a nail biter rather to the north
we have district four represented by
stephen horsford into the south
district three represented by suzy lee
both first term democrats trying to win
re-election
and results are not yet final but let's
take a look at the vote total so far
it's still unclear how many more votes
are left to come in
what we see so far is congresswoman
susie lee
having a narrow lead over her challenger
republican dan
rodimer district three represents the
south valley which includes part of las
vegas
henderson and boulder city in district
four
congressman stephen horsford is also on
top of his challenger so far
republican and former state assemblyman
jim marchant
that district covers part of las vegas
and the central portion of the state and
again margins remain
really close right now still too tight
too close to
call and again results are not yet final
reporting live this morning hector mejia
8 news now